[Applause]
look at you you're all
you're uh you're all dressed up you look
nice thanks thank you
[Laughter]
you bastard i know i just my socks are
now coming down too because that always
looks good too
you immediately look like 58 years old
when you do that
and you have a blue vein going down the
leg a metal detector it's all good it's
all not good yeah now okay stop
adjusting things it's it's going too far
yeah all right there you go you're
comfortable now you're already not so
much okay you'll be fine soon thank you
for being here thank you for having me a
lot of people excited about this uh this
anchorman movie of course it's a funny
movie a lot of funny people in it uh and
you have an impressive
mustache i have to say
in this movie
this gentleman is you grew this mustache
just was not fake
it's all uh all real no wigs no uh fake
and i grew i started growing the
mustache about uh there it is
that's the and i'm the reason i bring
this up is i can't do that
all right i have hair on my body i know
you want to know and now you know but uh
on my face i have patches where i can
grow columns of hair
like a column here and like a weirdly a
column here
the mustache area not so good there's
nothing going on up there so you grew a
nice stash literally i think it was the
day after my bar mitzvah full beard it
just happened
overnight and i just started i was able
to
just i need a bar mitzvah clearly yeah
yeah yeah it's uh i i've been able to
grow mustaches i and beards uh for for a
long time and i like doing it and and
okay
what kind of reactions do you do do
people treat you differently when you
have the the mustache they do
when i was when i was working on
anchorman i i there was one time where i
ran into an elevator and i was i was
kind of sweaty
uh and you have the full mustache and
the mutton chops my hair was
humid so it was looking really curly
uh and i was also wearing a t-shirt that
said mustache rides 25 cents
i just had it on oh yeah honestly i
don't know how that thing got hot
there was an elderly couple in the
elevator
uh and they
i it took me a second to realize that
they were really creeped out by the
combination sure yeah what a horrible
man you are yeah and uh and i realized
it halfway through so i i just kind of
sat and stared at him
always a good reaction when you think
you're intimidating someone is stare
them down yeah yeah and they were and
then as they walked off i i uh i told
them that i uh i had changed for a
dollar right nice
nice
nice you ruined their their nice
vacation
i'm told that you like to grow uh a
mustache on how around halloween and be
a different person with a mustache every
year a famous person every uh uh the
last several halloweens uh i've grown
mustaches and uh and tried to
incorporate them into costumes this is
you as who this does freddie mercury
freddie mercury last year that was
freddie mercury who and tell us who the
next person is oh that would be
gallagher
that was the year before and then i kept
actually i kept growing
uh a mustache for the following year uh
to be uh actually wilford brimley which
was let's see that yeah
you look amazing there that's incredible
well that one i was really now you
filled out your face yeah that took that
took three days of prosthetics yeah
you became in many ways brimley yeah
yeah it's hard to do
you never get old and you never die
that's the worst wilfred brimley
impersonation i've ever heard yeah i
think my clinton booby and trump is
starting to look really good yeah
you trumped me
yeah thanks
[Music]
oh
this is uh a lot of people say when they
make a movie you're drinking for too
long and it's weird uh
yeah i noticed these things that's good
scotch uh
a lot of people
when they do a movie say oh we had such
a fun cast yes and then you look at the
cast and you're like yeah that's not
true right but this cast i'm sorry i see
a lot of bs in this business and uh but
this but this is actually a really fun
cast you know a lot of funny people you
got mr kechner and carell and yourself
and uh
applegate you got this is a good time
you're having on this set it was it was
a blast did you all stay in the same
hotel and and sort of party together the
whole time
uh no actually i they all live in
california so i i stayed in a hotel but
they uh they didn't but
i had actually i did there was i was
there were some friends of mine that
were staying in the hotel at the same
time funny story
um i uh what a coincidence
we're on a talk show that led into uh
it's almost as if it were here
but it couldn't be like that and i
probably shouldn't say talk beforehand
the jury's still out actually on how
funny it is so i i won't i won't say for
sure that it's funny never good to say
up front boy have i got a hilarious
story for you seriously this will blow
you away um
look the confidence
great but i was uh i was staying in this
hotel and um a friend of mine was
staying in the hotel as well and i was
it was about two in the morning and i
was just kind of watching tv i couldn't
really sleep and i looked over and the
message light on my phone was flashing
so i thought that's weird it wasn't
flashing five minutes ago someone's just
left me a message
maybe it's my friend and then i checked
and
and it was it was a buddy of mine he's
like hey man look i didn't want to wake
you up but if you're if you're awake
come on up to uh room 55 there's a a
party there's a bunch of uh our friends
that are here it's really fun
you know it's it's i just think it's
you'd have a really good time so i
hung up ah that's two in the morning all
right so i got up and i got dressed and
i went up there and this music's playing
really loud and i'm just banging on the
door saying open up open up security
open up right and also the music went
down so it is pretty loud i could hear
on the other side
yeah and uh and they said we'll turn it
down i said open the door now we've had
many complain i started being like a
real jerk right right and uh and then i
just heard from behind the door i don't
know he has curly hair and glasses
opened the door it's just started
screaming and then finally after about
three minutes the door open
and it was a val kilmer
what
yeah it was his room i've no i don't
know val i've never been
you don't know the guy no never and i
was like oh uh hey um yeah my uh
friend sam said that he was up here he's
like uh um
oh come on in and
oh god and
there was nobody there oh make sense
like him and like a friend of his two
people see your friend playing a nice
mean joke totally so what do you say to
val kilmer though that was weird he said
out maybe he's out on the on the deck
cause they're like a loud door so i
walked out there there was no one out
there yeah
and so then i walked out i was like kind
of walk and and it was so awkward that
uh i should have obviously just said i'm
sorry and and left but it
was just me and val kilmer so i i was
like
so how's it going man
that's the best part it's just like
[Applause]
it's pretty
yeah good good all right we'll see you
later yeah yeah
wow that is bad
yeah i would die inside a little bit